We can capture the basic intuition behind work on cognitive architectures by
a simple equation, architecture plus content equals behavior.
Let us look at this equation from two different perspectives.
First, imagine that you want to design an intelligent machine
that exhibits a particular kind of behavior. This equation says that,
in order to do that, you have to design the right architecture, and
then put the right kind of knowledge content into that architecture,
to get the behavior that you want from it. That's a complicated thing.
But suppose that I could fix the architecture for you. In that case,
if the architecture is fixed, I simply have to change the knowledge content to
get different behaviors, which is a really powerful idea. From a different
direction, suppose that we were trying to understand human behavior.
Now we could say, again, that the architecture is fixed, we could say that,
this behavior is arising because the knowledge content is different.
We can map now, behavior to content because the architecture is fixed.
That simplifies our understanding of how to design machines or how to understand
human cognition. By the way, the same thing happens in computer architecture.
I'm sure you have, are familiar with computer architecture.
Computer architecture has stored programs in it, that's the content, and
that running of the stored program gives you different behaviors.
The computer architecture doesn't change, the stored program keeps on changing,
to give you different kind of behaviors. Same idea with cognitive architectures.
Keep the architecture constant, change the content. Now, of course,
the big question will become,
what is a good architecture? And that's what we'll examine later.